salut la team menthe à l'eau aujourd'hui
on va parler d'astrologie je sais c'est
pas du tout le sujet que je vous avais
annoncé lundi mais entre temps dans les
commentaires il ya une grosse discussion
sur la commentaires de la vidéo de
vendredi dernier concernant l'astrologie
les scientifiques je suis pas intervenu
dans votre discussion vous avez remarqué
parce que je me suis dit que c'était
sympa de faire une vidéo du coup sur ce
thème là et là vous vous dites alors il
est pur qui fabrique et bien je suis
pour ni l'un ni l'autre et les deux en
même temps la bonne technique du mec qui
se mouille pas l'astrologie c'est une
croyance avons tout comme toutes les
croyances ça peut dire qu'elle peut être
vérifiable et validé par une autre
croyance qu'est le monde scientifique ou
alors pas du tout et elle ne concernera
toujours uniquement les gens qui croient
donc comme toutes les croyances
elle se respecte par contre quand on est
mentaliste c'est très intéressant de
prendre en compte le rapport à
l'astrologie
tout d'abord parce que de nombreux
astrologues alors attention petit point
quand même je ne dis pas qu'il ya des
vrais défauts des charlatans des spas
charlatans je prends juste le point de
vue mentalist donc je disais certains
astrologues use et abuse de l'effet
barnum des lieux communs et nous avec
notre petit recadrage on a l'impression
qu'ils s'adressent à nous à notre
personne je vais vous lire un extrait
d'angel stagnaro à ce sujet c'est pour
ça que j'ai fait la vidéo d'ailleurs
parce que quand je lisais vos
commentaires ça m'a fait immédiatement
penser à ça j'ai compris l'efficacité
d'utiliser l'horoscope asiatique quand
un de mes amis qui croyait furieusement
me l'a présenté comme il s'était trompé
sur mon année de naissance
il avait lu la description des
caractéristiques du mauvais signe j'ai
été intrigué de voir à quel point cette
lecture semblait exact je lui ai donc
demandé de me prêter ce livre j'ai
vérifié une fois encore les dates et
j'ai trouvé l'erreur j'ai regardé
l'horoscope qui correspondaient
effectivement à mon année de naissance
et j'ai trouvé une autre lecture encore
une fois exact c'est vrai qu'en salle un
recadrage c'est très fort on a toujours
l'impression que ça s'adresse à nous et
en tout cas inconsciemment on leur
accroche à des choses qui vont
fonctionner et on va oublier ce qui ne
fonctionne pas au final on va toujours
se reconnaître mais ce qui est très très
intéressant par contre d'un point de vue
société c'est que toute sa vie on va
lire des descriptifs sur un autre signe
astrologique
on va aller à la chasse à ça dans les
bouquins qu'on y croit ou pas on est
toujours tenté de lire la description de
son signe et les descriptions sont
toujours les mêmes évidemment les traits
de caractères principaux ce que la
personne aime ou on aime pas ce pour
quoi elle est faite on lui lit tellement
on sent un prime tellement au cours de
sa vie qu'on peut s'y reconnaître les
yeux fermés même si c'est pas vraiment
nous je m'explique par exemple si je
rencontre une personne qui est née le 27
mars donc qu'ils aient bélier je veux
dire à cette personne qu'elle a plutôt
besoin de liberté
c'est quelqu'un de téméraires que c'est
une leader que c'est quelqu'un de même
d'un petit peu impulsive qui est franche
et directe qui est mme laventure mais
qui est plutôt impatient de voir même
agressif brutal parfois et je pense donc
que cette personne-là éveillé mais je
savais qu'elle était bélier puisque là
dans l'exemple je sais qu'elle est née
le 27 mars la personne bélier va se
reconnaître dans ses traits de caractère
même si elle ne l'est pas parce que tout
au long de sa vie c'est les traits de
caractère du bélier keller à lui donc
elle s'est associée elle même à ce
qu'elle a lu tout le temps et ça c'est
très intéressant ça veut pas dire
qu'elle l'est comme ça ça veut dire qu
elle se reconnaît l'album je vous ai
fait le big hill je vous cite rapidement
tous les autres signes avec un moyen
mnémotechnique pour se rappeler des
informations clé pour toro je vous fait
voir à chaque fois la lettre à quoi elle
me fait penser tempéré m la simplicité
immuable mu abl réaliste et obstiné et
affectueux affectueux je vais faire
comme ça pour chaque signe gémeaux
généreux et insaisissable imaginatif et
intelligent négatif talentueux
talentueux dans le sens multiples
talents cancer conservateur apathique
original chaleureux énergique romantique
lyon leader optimiste original naturel
extravertie on peut dire l'yonne vierge
vraiment doué indécise esprit pratique
raffiné grande intelligence et
observatrice balance bon goût impartiale
frivole artistes sens c'est le n 2
sensible réceptif équilibré scorpions
sexualité très contrôlée optimiste
réservez en paroles passionné un temps
ouvert d'esprit sensible c'est encore le
n 2 sensible sagittaire se suffit à
lui-même actif généreux un patient très
fiable et honnête très rigide adaptable
idéaliste réticents à manifester
l'affection et sincère et les trois
derniers donc capricorne confiance en
lui-même autoritaire prévisible résolu
indépendant circonspect obstiné sûr
c'est le r de la fin 2 / non frivole et
solide verso vif et actif raisonnable
sans préjugés et idéaliste aimable et
peu conventionnel c'est le u2 peut alors
mon moyen mnémotechnique a ses failles
mais c'est celui
en tout cas j'utilise et enfin le
dernier le poisson populaire courront
s'il y en a
idéaliste sensible soumis compréhensif
et négligent va falloir que ça change
les poissons voilà vous m'aviez vraiment
inspiré avec ses commentaires donc je
tenais à faire une vidéo dessus la vidéo
sur la négociation et avoir une
augmentation etc je la ferai quand même
la semaine prochaine c'est juste heureux
reporter dans le temps parce que c'était
chouette de rebondir et sur ce côté
assez drôle que j'ai pu vérifier par
moi-même que les gens se reconnaissent
dans les descriptifs de leur signe même
si ce n'est pas ce qu'ils sont vraiment
n'oubliez pas que demain je fais ma faq
via twitter parce qu'il fallait passer
par twitter pour changer un petit peu
les réseaux sur lesquels je fais les faq
c'est la faq pour fêter les trente mille
donc le hashtag pour poser votre
question qui doit être en rapport avec
les vidéos c'est mentalisme 30000 le
mentalisme du futur vous avez encore
jusqu'à ce soir 20h après je vais faire
la vidéo
merci d'avoir gardé celle ci si elle
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à me le faire
savoir en mettant un petit et
imprévisible mais astrologie pouce en
l'air
vous pouvez également laisser un
commentaire je lis tous les commentaires
en ce moment j'y réponds - j'y répondrai
plus plus tard chez en train de vous
préparer les vidéos cet été merci à tous
ceux et celles qui font des sous-titrés
revenons à chaque fois en bas des
descriptifs dès que vous faites des sous
titres c'est automatisé par youtube et
ça rend les vidéos accessibles aux
malentendants donc bravo de temps en
temps je pense à vous le dire parce que
vraiment vous le méritez je sais que
vous passez du temps là dessus n'oubliez
pas de vous avez des avant de partir
puisque le mental blog c'est une vidéo
par jour pendant un an depuis le 1er
janvier donc rendez vous demain à 17
heures ciao
nous